lundi 14 novembre aux alentours de 22h
l'Américain Mister veste a
officiellement dépassé le Suédois
pewdiepie et devenu le youtubeur le plus
suivi au monde alors avec cette vidéo
vous allez découvrir son parcours et son
histoire comprendre comment il a réussi
à construire son empire et quels sont
les leçons à en tirer et avant de
commencer je tiens à remercier jelly
smack qui a accepté de nous soutenir en
étant partenaire de cette vidéo jelly
smack c'est donc une entreprise qui aide
les créateurs de contenu du monde entier
à développer leur potentiel au maximum
et aujourd'hui elle est partenaire des
plus gros créateurs comme par exemple Mr
Beast dont on va parler donc dans cette
vidéo alors pour ça jelly smack s'appuie
sur deux offres majeures le créateur
programme et jellyfy le créateur
programme en fait ça permet à vous en
tant que créateur de contenu d'étendre
votre présence sur les réseaux sociaux
concrètement si vous êtes un créateur de
contenu et que vous publiez des vidéos
sur YouTube et bien jelly smack via ses
outils de technologie va se charger de
les adapter et de les publier sur
d'autres plateformes quelle qu'elle soit
vous vous portez donc aucune dépense ni
aucun risque et Jenny smack supporte
l'intégralité des investissements le
tout contre une rémunération sur une
partie des revenus publicitaires générés
par les chaînes qu'il gère pour vous
donc si jamais ça vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas à les contacter via le
lien qui apparaît juste ici et qui est
aussi en description autre offre par
ailleurs qui peut vous intéresser si
vous êtes créateur de contenu c'est
jennify un outil de financement qui va
vous aider à aller plus loin dans le
développement de vos nouveaux projets en
fait l'algorithme de Jelly smack analyse
les performances de vos vidéos sur
YouTube et on estime ainsi les gains
futurs ensuite et bien ils peuvent vous
avancer une somme d'argent pour que vous
puissiez l'investir directement dans
votre projet le lien est juste ici mais
aussi en description chez mes volets
découvrir la valeur de vos contenus bref
merci à jelly smack pour son soutien je
vous mets les liens en description et
maintenant installez-vous
confortablement bienvenue d'ailleurs à
tous les nouveaux qui s'abonnent il y a
plein de belles choses qui arrivent sur
la chaîne on est parti tout de suite
[Musique]
de YouTube
WhatsApp
alors jimmy a commencé très jeune à
s'intéresser à YouTube en fait c'est
même à 13 ans qu'il crée sa chaîne
Youtube en 2012 donc lorsqu'il apprend
que l'un de ses créateurs préférés vous
disent gamertech a quitté son emploi
pour se consacrer pleinement justement à
YouTube et ça peut vous paraître anodin
aujourd'hui de gagner sa vie avec
Youtube mais à l'époque très peu de
vidéastes vivaient réellement de leur
métier pour vous donner une idée en
France à ce moment-là Cyprien sortait
tout juste de son clash avec cortex et
l'ÉNAC situation comme moi d'ailleurs
était encore au collège en train de
passer le brevet jimmy a donc choisi
comme pseudo Mr Beast 6000 un pseudo qui
l'utilisait en fait sur sa Xbox
lorsqu'il a commencé à jouer en ligne
aux jeux vidéo et comme beaucoup de
jeunes youtubeurs à l'époque ses
premiers contenus c'était surtout du
coup sur des jeux vidéo Minecraft
notamment en premier
Jimmy est d'abord très secret sur sa
chaîne Youtube et sa mère qui vit avec
elle ne connaît pas la nouvelle passion
de son enfant donc la journée il va à
l'école et la nuit discrètement et bien
il enregistre ses vidéos dans sa chambre
et d'ailleurs sa mère raconte qu'elle
n'entendait parler parfois seul dans sa
chambre et elle pensait soit quelque
chose qui allait pas bien soit
simplement qui parlait à des amis
directement en ligne
alors le début était très loin d'être
facile et Jimmy raconte qu'au collège il
était pointé du doigt comme le geek fan
de YouTube un peu bizarre personne ne
partageait en fait cette passion avec
lui il faut savoir qu'au début des
années 2010 c'est pas du tout comme
aujourd'hui peu de gens suivent et
regardent YouTube en tout cas comme
aujourd'hui et c'est pas forcément
classe d'être un youtubeur on en connaît
et on en suit éventuellement
quelques-uns mais ça a pas forcément
au-delà
YouTube
alors malgré tout cela pendant des
années Mister V va continuer à faire des
vidéos régulièrement et un peu plus tard
vers 18-19 ans il a commencé à prendre
contact avec d'autres créateurs de
contenu qui faisaient donc des vidéos
sur YouTube en fait ils discutait avec
beaucoup d'entre eux et c'est en fait
l'une des premières recettes de son
succès que je propose qu'on voit
ensemble en fait sa théorie est assez
simple lorsque tu travailles seul certes
tu peux faire des erreurs et apprendre
de ses erreurs mais ça va pas forcément
au-delà alors que si tu travailles main
dans la main avec disons quatre autres
youtubeurs et bien peut-être que tes
amis vont eux aussi faire des erreurs et
donc à ce moment-là vous allez apprendre
et vous améliorer ensemble à partir de
toutes les erreurs que vous avez pu
faire autrement dit pour dire les choses
simplement c'est du gain de temps parce
que tout le monde progresse ensemble
bref très vite Mr Beast va quitter un
petit peu les jeux vidéo pour
s'intéresser à l'actualité et pas
l'actualité politique ça serait mais en
l'occurrence l'actualité de youtube il
va donc parler de pewdiepie ou encore
des revenus des youtubeurs il a alors
plus de 10000 abonnés sa mère découvre
sa chaîne Youtube et une idée va le
faire complètement changer de dimension
[Musique]
et oui son premier succès ce ne sera pas
une vidéo de gaming ou alors sur les
revenus des youtubeurs mais ce sera
celle-ci c'était dans une société
effectivement 5 ans avant sensem les
vrais savent dans cette vidéo on est
parti pour compter jusqu'à 100000 va
donc se lancer dans le défi assez
improbable il va compter jusqu'à 100000
se filmer en train de le faire et le
balancer directement sur YouTube à ce
moment là les vues explosent et il
décide alors de reproduire le concept
scénario du film be et à chaque fois en
fait qu'il tombe sur le mot abeille donc
bille en français et bien il doit redire
tous les mots abeilles du scénario je
sais pas c'est très clair dit comme ça
je vous laisse donc avec un extrait
alors visiblement peu convaincu par le
fait de compter jusqu'à 100 000 sa mère
lui met un ultimatum soit il va à
l'université et il peut rester du coup à
la maison soit il arrête ses études pour
se concentrer sur Youtube mais dans ce
cas il doit quitter le domicile familial
Jimmy va donc décider d'aller à
l'université et c'est alors la fin de
son aventure YouTube
non évidemment vous l'imaginez c'est pas
le cas en fait il va arrêter les cours
au bout de deux semaines sans rien dire
à sa mère et pendant des semaines après
ça il va se garer chaque jour sur le
parking de sa fac et à ce moment-là il
va en profiter pour monter des vidéos
directement dans sa voiture et en soit
je valide l'idée à titre personnel c'est
même arrivé de tourner plusieurs fois
les actus du jour directement dans la
voiture et je valide à 100% le son est
plutôt pas mal donc pourquoi pas bref
avec ces défis ces vidéos comment ça
fonctionnait de plus en plus il commence
aussi à gagner de l'argent avec Youtube
il annonce alors à sa mère qu'il quitte
la fac et qu'il va déménager et là il
raconte que ses journées se résumaient à
se lever à taffer sur Youtube et à se
coucher il passe parfois 10 heures en
Skype avec d'autres créateurs de contenu
pour parler justement de youtube il
attend d'ailleurs assez rapidement les
100 000 abonnés et la surprise une
marque le contact et lui propose 5000
dollars pour une vidéo c'est son premier
contrat avec une marque en contrat qui
pourrait lui permettre de s'acheter du
matériel plus performant de financer
aussi de nouvelles vidéos et pourtant
malgré ce montant important quand on
commence sur Youtube et bien Jimmy
refuse
[Musique]
mais en fait c'est Jimmy refuse c'est
pour demander finalement le double à la
marque c'est à dire donc 10000 dollars
pour lui c'est très clair c'est soit
10000 dollars soit rien du tout et oui
comme sa mère visiblement Jimmy aime
bien les ultimatums ici Jimmy demande
10000 dollars c'est en fait pour donner
cet argent à un sans-abri et 5000
dollars selon lui et bien c'était tout
simplement pas assez accrocheur pour en
faire une bonne vidéo avec un bon titre
il veut donc donner 10 000 dollars un
sans-abri et la marque accepte la vidéo
à ce moment-là cartonne
en fait ici au-delà évidemment de
l'audience c'est la réaction des gens
leur visage qui change quand on leur
apprend une telle nouvelle pour lui
aucun doute il faut reproduire ce format
et donc quelques semaines plus tard il
poste alors une nouvelle vidéo dans
laquelle il se filme en train de donner
100 dollars de pourboire à des livreurs
de pizza
peu à peu Mister Beast va commencer à
distribuer des centaines puis des
milliers de dollars dans chacune de ces
vidéos 1000 dollars par exemple à des
sans-abris 10000 dollars un chauffeur
uber ou encore 50 000 dollars à un
inconnu et même d'ailleurs 100000
dollars à sa mère pour rembourser le
prêt de sa maison
à partir de là Mister V entra alors dans
une nouvelle dimension sur youtube il va
même jusqu'à acheter une maison à l'une
de ses abonnés
[Applaudissements]
et vous l'aurez compris en plus de faire
plaisir à différentes personnes ça fait
aussi plaisir à ceux qui le suivent et
donc ça a un impact sur sa chaîne en
fait en un an c'est assez hallucinant il
est passé de 1 million à 10 millions
d'abonnés c'est donc une ascension
fulgurante qu'on peut expliquer
notamment par un attrait donc pour ces
vidéos là mais plus largement par le
fait que depuis le début tout ce que Mr
Beast gagne et bien il le dépense le
mois prochain dans sa prochaine vidéo
YouTube et pour dire les choses par
exemple c'est gagne 10000 dollars dans
une vidéo et bien le mois prochain il va
dépenser 10000 dollars dans une nouvelle
vidéo pareil s'il gagne 100000 dollars
il mettra 100000 dollars dans la
suivante et jusqu'à des valeurs assez
importantes s'ils gagnent un million il
sera capable de mettre près d'un million
sur la vidéo suivante aujourd'hui Mister
Beast affirme dépenser entre quatre et
cinq millions par mois en vidéo alors
comment on arrive à dépenser 4 millions
de dollars par mois en faisant des
vidéos et bien par exemple en faisant ça
[Musique]
pendant les trois années suivantes Mr
Bean va peu à peu augmenter le niveau de
production de ces vidéos et derrière
chaque défi qu'il tente de réaliser il y
a des dizaines de personnes qui
travaillent autour de lui j'appelle donc
à des ingénieurs pour savoir comment
réaliser le défi puis à des personnes
pour construire les décors puis
évidemment à toute une team de
production des monteurs etc il met donc
à chaque fois énormément de moyens dans
la production il va toujours chercher à
aller plus loin que ce qui a déjà été
fait et par exemple alors qu'il
approchait des 20 millions d'abonnés il
a eu comme idée de planter un million
d'arbres très vite les experts lui ont
dit que planter un million d'arbres
c'était impossible car il faut déjà des
heures pour planter sans arbre il
comprend alors qu'il pourra pas planter
tous ces arbres lui-même ça va lui
prendrait des années ce serait un taf à
temps plein avec toute une équipe
derrière du coup il s'est dit qu'il
allait plutôt financer une fondation une
fondation lui garantissait que pour un
dollar il pouvait planter un arbre il se
donne alors pour mission de récolter 20
millions de dollars donc pour planter 20
millions d'arbres à l'occasion de ces 1
million d'abonnés le chiffre a
finalement été atteint Elon Musk a même
donné un million de dollars et après 3
ans les 20 millions d'arbres ont été
plantés bref Mr Bean va toujours aller
plus loin et un autre exemple va prouver
sa détermination il va s'enterrer vivant
pendant 50 heures
[Musique]
là encore vous l'imaginez il a mis des
gros moyens sur le coup déjà pour sa
sécurité il lui fallait un cercueil
construit sur mesure avec une pompe à
oxygène ce qui normalement et pas
quelque chose qu'on installe sur un
cercueil et surtout quelque chose de
transparent pour voir le créateur à
l'intérieur dans une interview en fait
il explique que rien que le cercueil ça
lui a coûté
243000 dollars
la vidéo va à nouveau être un carton
beaucoup de médias d'ailleurs vont en
parler mais ce n'est pas sur ça que j'ai
envie d'attirer votre attention c'est
plus en fait sur la façon dont Mr Beast
a construit cette vidéo en fait au fil
des années il a mis au point une façon
bien particulière de commencer ses
vidéos
9 secondes et en 9 secondes Mister veste
a présenté l'essentiel du concept il se
trouve d'ailleurs déjà dans le cercueil
bref en l'espace de quelques instants
c'est déjà très clair pour ceux qui ont
cliqué sur la vidéo
ce genre d'entre eux très courte il faut
savoir que c'est vraiment une marque de
fabrique de Mr Beast exemple encore plus
court avec une autre vidéo
ici en 18 mots on comprend ce qu'on va
voir dans la vidéo et surtout et bien la
vidéo commence très très rapidement
alors heureusement personnellement j'ai
pas mal changé depuis mais à titre de
comparaison par rapport à Mr Bean voici
mes intros de vidéos à l'époque salut
c'est Hugo j'espère que vous allez bien
aujourd'hui on va parler de vacances
scolaires
[Musique]
bref on peut commencer en fait Mr Beast
explique dans une interview à collidens
Samir que il fait des réunions avec son
équipe où il passe énormément de temps
mais énormément de temps juste à
réfléchir à ces fameuses intros ça se
joue donc dans les mots mais ça se joue
aussi dans le visuel par exemple le fait
d'avoir plusieurs angles de caméra
parler d'une caméra et une autre très
rapidement tout ça a forcément un impact
sur l'attention du public
alors pourquoi accorder autant
d'importance à 10 secondes sur les plus
de 10 minutes qui vont constituer la
vidéo alors si vous êtes vous-même
créateur de contenu je pense que vous
êtes au courant mais en fait tout se
joue sur les 10 premières secondes en
fait si vous êtes dans votre canapé
tranquillement le soir et que vous
voulez regarder une vidéo sur Youtube
vous cliquez sur une vidéo mais si au
bout de 15 secondes vous avez
l'impression que ça ne correspond pas à
ce que vous vouliez juste que ça ne vous
intéresse pas vous allez quitter la
vidéo là où c'est particulièrement
important sur Youtube c'est que
l'algorithme de YouTube va mettre en
avant les vidéos dans lequel la
rétention est élevée donc la rétention
c'est la durée moyenne de visionnage ou
le pourcentage moyen de la vidéo qui
regardait en moyenne par le public alors
forcément c'est dans les 10 premières
secondes vous perdez déjà 50% des gens
qui ont cliqué sur la vidéo ça fait une
grosse perte et ça aura donc forcément
un impact sur l'algorithme de YouTube et
sur la façon dont votre vidéo est mise
en avant sur la plateforme bon et
au-delà même de ces 10 premières
secondes qui sont connues aujourd'hui
quand même de beaucoup de youtubeurs en
fait toute la vidéo est construite de
façon à ce qu'on s'ennuie le moins
possible au montage la vidéo va être
coupée de façon très très dynamique de
façon à garder uniquement les meilleurs
moments et faire en sorte donc que les
gens ne s'ennuient pas le résultat c'est
quoi et bien une vidéo ou Mister Beast
sans terre pendant 50 heures va devenir
une simple vidéo de 13 minutes
ultra condensé et d'ailleurs cette forme
d'efficacité on la voit sur deux types
de contenus par exemple je sais pas si
tu vas offrir 10000 dollars à quelqu'un
il va offrir les 10000 dollars on va
voir la réaction en quelques secondes
seulement de celui qui reçoit les 10000
dollars et à ce moment-là on passe à
autre chose et au passage là dessus
c'est intéressant de comprendre que
c'est pas la seule recette qui est
possible déjà il y a plein d'autres
façons de faire du contenu qui
fonctionne sur Youtube et il y a des
contenus
et c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que
certaines vidéos qui parfois ont coûté
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
à faire ne sont jamais sortis
[Musique]
au total d'après Mr Beast plus de 100
vidéos pour sa chaîne principale ont été
tournées montées mais jamais publié ça
représente quasiment une vidéo sur 4 qui
termine à la poubelle et oui car malgré
des réunions d'équipes qui permettent de
créer la meilleure vidéo sur le papier
et bien dans la réalité ensuite lors du
tournage par exemple et bien certaines
vidéos peuvent se retrouver moins bien
qu'elles en avaient l'air au départ
alors plusieurs choses pourraient poser
problème ça peut être des décors qui
sont plus fade que prévu une vidéo qui
est moins drôle constipée ou encore un
tournage qui ne s'est pas passé comme
prévu
anitas et l'exemple parfait c'est cette
vidéo
en fait dans une interview qu'il a donné
à Coline and Samir et bien Mr Beast
raconte ça
12 versions de la vidéo tout simplement
car Mr Beast jugeait que les décors
rendent faux pour celle-ci est
finalement sortie mais vous l'aurez
compris c'est pas le cas de toutes Jimmy
par exemple un jour a voulu escalader un
mur avec des ventouses il a donc
embauché des ingénieurs il a construit
du matériel pour tester tout ça et au
final il s'est rendu compte que c'était
vraiment pas possible autre exemple il a
un jour voulu manger le plus grand
cookies au monde sauf que il s'est rendu
compte que le manger entièrement n'était
pas forcément la meilleure chose à faire
pour sa santé du coup sur ce projet
précis il a décidé de pas mettre sa
santé en danger il a donc abandonné
l'idée bon il y a un autre exemple que
je vais vous montrer en fait Mr Beast
avait l'idée de faire une sorte de
Courtepaille pour les 7 merveilles du
monde et en gros chacune des 7 personnes
de l'équipe de Mr Beast devait ensuite y
aller sur chacune donc de ces merveilles
du monde
la vidéo n'a tout simplement pas été
publié pour une raison assez simple ils
ont pas trouvé une bonne miniature pour
cette vidéo et ça nous amène un autre
point important que Mr Beast prend en
compte dans son contenu en plus de la
question de la rétention faire en sorte
que les gens donc restent tout le long
de la vidéo un autre élément essentiel
c'est la question de la miniature sur
Youtube
alors Mr Bean raconte qu'il dépense
autant en fait pour s'assurer que ce
soit la meilleure miniature possible et
derrière ce prix absolument faramineux
on peut supposer qu'il s'agit aussi d'un
moyen de s'assurer de l'exclusivité de
sa recette en gros que son graphiste
n'aille pas faire la même chose ailleurs
pour un concurrent bon est-ce qu'on peut
noter c'est que Mister Beast ne prépare
pas qu'une seule miniature par vidéo il
en a souvent plusieurs en stock et très
récemment encore Mister veste a changé
trois fois la miniature pour une seule
vidéo bon et là pour le coup c'est pas
propre que à Mister Beast faut savoir
que sur Hugo décrypse Benjamin qui
d'ailleurs travaille sur cette vidéo
mais qui prépare aussi la plupart des
miniatures de la chaîne et bien réalise
souvent deux ou trois miniatures pour
chaque vidéo l'idée c'est de faire en
sorte que si la première ne fonctionne
pas et bien on en a une seconde au cas
où qu'on peut changer et directement
mettre en ligne bon tout ça pour dire
que Mr Beast a poussé cette question des
miniatures à l'extrême à tout point de
vue aujourd'hui ça a clairement inspiré
beaucoup de monde c'est devenu une
tendance plus large qu'on retrouve y
compris en France avec des miniatures
relativement similaires bon je parle
beaucoup depuis tout à l'heure mais je
vous ai toujours pas parlé du plus gros
succès de Mr Beast sur Youtube un succès
qui révèle beaucoup beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
le 17 septembre 2021 Netflix sort squid
game une série sud-coréenne qui se
transforme très vite en carton mondiale
et un mois et demi plus tard Mister mist
sort sa sa version de Squid game une
vidéo de 25 minutes où il reconstitue
chaque épreuve de la série
[Applaudissements]
c'est littéralement le plus gros projet
de Mr Beast à l'heure actuelle 20
cameraman 20 monteurs sans figurant un
gagnant qui gagne un demi million de
dollars bref la vidéo va lui coûter au
total 3,5 millions de dollars mais selon
Mr Beast cet investissement valait le
coup en fait cette vidéo lui a permis
d'étendre sa popularité dans le monde
entier la vidéo a été vue évidemment aux
États-Unis mais aussi en Europe en Asie
ou encore en Amérique du Sud en trois
jours elle est atteint les 150 millions
de vues sur Youtube c'est absolument
immense le résultat est direct en 30
jours il totalise plus de 10 millions
d'abonnés en plus et aujourd'hui ce
contenu culmine quasiment à 300 millions
de vues il faut bien comprendre qu'il y
a vraiment un avant et un après squid
game pour Mr Beast c'est vraiment une
étape qui lui a permis de passer d'un
grand youtubeur américain en grand
youtubeur mondial et si on regarde en
France énormément de médias ont relié
cette vidéo dans le monde également peu
importe en fait le continent et une
langue parlée et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
il y a même plus cette barrière de la
langue pour Mr Beast puisque chaque
vidéo est traduite et publiée sur des
chaînes annexes il y a donc Mr Beast en
français chaque décor de Squid game dans
la vraie vie Mr Bean en Espagne
aujourd'hui compte plus d'un million
d'abonnés et d'ailleurs ce qui est assez
marrant c'est que pour faire connaître
ces chaînes comme ça en différentes
langues et bien il va payer des
placements de produits un peu comme
pourrait le faire des marques sauf que
lui c'est pour faire la promotion de sa
chaîne Youtube en France par exemple il
a payé amixem justement pour mettre en
avant sa chaîne cette vidéo est
sponsorisée par un youtubeur cette vidéo
est sponsorisée par Mr Beast
bon et depuis le lancement de ces
chaînes en différentes langues on notera
que YouTube a intégré une nouvelle
fonctionnalité qui permet en fait
d'ajouter un doublage donc de
sélectionner en fait la langue de
visionnage d'une vidéo ce que fait
d'ailleurs Mr Beast sur sa chaîne donc
en gros aujourd'hui si vous allez sur la
chaîne principale disons de Mr Beast
celle donc en anglais vous pouvez
directement choisir de regarder la vidéo
en français un peu comme vous pourriez
le faire par exemple sur Netflix
[Musique]
et oui en août 2022 donc très récemment
Mister Beast franchit la barre des 100
millions d'abonnés après pewdiepie donc
le même youtubeur dont il analysait
lui-même le contenu et les revenus 7 ans
auparavant et pour fêter ses 100
millions d'abonnés il décide donc
d'aller encore plus loin et d'offrir
directement une île
et
c'est ça
[Musique]
nous permet de revenir sur l'une des
recettes importantes qui explique le
succès de Mister Beast c'est la question
de l'entourage de Mr Beast qu'on voit
dans les vidéos en gros dans tous ces
contenus que ce soit celle-ci avec Lille
que ce soit squid game ou même la vidéo
où ils s'enterre vivant sur chacune de
ces vidéos et bien les potes de Jimmy
sont présents directement à l'écran
c'est donc des personnages à part
entière du contenu qui participent qui
font des blagues etc
on retrouve notamment évidemment Carl
qui est là depuis le quasi tout début
c'était au départ en fait un monteur
engagé par le frère de Mr Beast il a
ensuite rejoint Mr Beast pour devenir
monteur puis caméraman et puis il est
apparu dans une vidéo cache-cache c'est
aujourd'hui l'un des streamers les plus
suivis aux États-Unis
et tout cela est très réfléchi de la
part de Jimmy l'idée de faire participer
ses potes dans ces vidéos il raconte
dans un documentaire que l'idée lui est
venu lorsqu'il faisait des vidéos à
l'époque avec son plus vieil ami Chris
Tyson qui a rencontré à l'école de la
même façon que le fait s'entourer avec
d'autres créateurs ou une équipe en
coulisses lui permettait d'aller plus
vite et bien s'entourer des personnes
aussi à l'écran lui permet d'avoir des
vidéos plus divertissantes c'est comme
ça donc qu'il est allé chercher Tarik
l'un des membres donc de son équipe
c'était un comédien il travaillait dans
un hôpital pour payer à côté ses
factures à ce moment-là Mr Beast il
avait près d'un million d'abonnés il est
allé voir un spectacle de Tariq et à la
fin il est allé voir Tariq il lui a dit
écoute
et qu'on travaille ensemble sur Mr Beast
bon je vous apprends rien on le voit ces
dernières années sur Youtube l'effet de
bande fonctionne très bien et les très
recherchée par les youtubeurs que ce
soit amixem qui a véritablement recruté
des personnes pour travailler avec lui
sur les vidéos y compris à l'écran mais
on peut parler aussi de Pierre Croce
avec maison grise ou alors plus
récemment d'ici avec Sacha Benji et
toute la monde qu'on retrouve dans
toutes ces vidéos aujourd'hui bref Jimmy
c'est son tour et c'est également le cas
derrière la caméra son manager depuis
plus de 5 ans s'appelle ride hutchers et
il avait travaillé pour la chaîne d'une
perfect auparavant c'est avec lui
notamment que Mr Beast va entrer dans
une nouvelle dimension très intéressante
actuellement une dimension en dehors de
YouTube en dehors des réseaux sociaux
même c'est le dernier chapitre qu'on va
voir ensemble
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'une des principales
préoccupations disons des créateurs de
contenu sur Internet ça revient à faire
des choses au-delà justement d'Internet
et dans la vraie vie si on peut dire ça
comme ça et de la même manière que les
influenceuses lancent leur marque de
cosmétiques Mr Beast lui a décidé de
lancer une chaîne et pas n'importe
quelle chaîne une chaîne de fast food et
Mister Beast est habitué vous l'aurez
compris à des grosses productions sur
Youtube et bien c'est la même chose pour
le lancement de sa chaîne de restaurant
il a pas ouvert un ou deux restaurants
mais directement 300 restaurants en une
journée disponible en ligne et à
l'époque en fait l'engouement était elle
qu'il y avait pas assez livreur pour
distribuer tous les hamburgers bref des
restaurants il a aussi développé des
chocolats mais on peut aussi noter et
bien une chaîne dédiée à la
philanthropie et oui au-delà de toutes
les chaînes qu'il a aujourd'hui et
encore j'ai pas tout évoqué notamment
ces chaînes liées au gaming il a aussi
une chaîne dédiée à la philanthropie qui
a plus de 10 millions d'abonnés et pour
lui avec cette chaîne l'objectif est
très clair faire en sorte que tous les
revenus liés à la chaîne et même
d'autres revenus au delà soit investis
pour aider les gens il avait par exemple
ouvert un restaurant ou la nourriture
était gratuite pour ceux qui venaient et
qui étaient dans le besoin il a
également annoncé récemment à travailler
sur une levée de fonds d'environ 150
millions de dollars qu'ils
souhaiteraient collecter dans l'objectif
de développer encore davantage de sa
diversification via par exemple ces
restos ou encore d'autres projets à côté
[Musique]
alors grâce à tout ce qu'on vient
d'évoquer sa capacité à réinvestir à se
diversifier ou encore à être exigeant
sur son contenu aujourd'hui Mr Beast est
devenu le plus gros youtubeur au monde
et avec une équipe dont le nombre précis
reste d'ailleurs encore secret il
dépense près de 4 millions de dollars
par mois pour faire ces vidéos sur
toutes ces chaînes il possède une
dizaine de chaînes YouTube dont sa
principale donc à 110 millions d'abonnés
il se diversifie progressivement dans
plein d'autres activités et encore on
n'a pas pu tout évoquer aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs en préparant cette vidéo avec
Benjamin qui est journaliste donc au
sein de l'équipe je suis retombé sur
cette vidéo qui a été postée il y a deux
ans c'est une vidéo ou Mister Beast ce
film en 2015 en train de dire ce qui
l'espère idéalement pour le Jimmy dans 5
ans le Jimmy donc en 2020
et il faut le dire ça fait assez bizarre
de voir ça aujourd'hui quand on connaît
son succès alors si cette vidéo vous a
plu pour soutenir notre travail pensez à
vous abonner je vous invite aussi à
découvrir le reste des vidéos qui sont
disponibles sur la chaîne je pense que
ça pourrait potentiellement vous plaire
par ailleurs pour suivre l'actualité du
jour au quotidien rendez-vous sur notre
chaîne dédiée aux actus du jour je vous
mets le lien directement en description
sachant que ce format des accuses jours
qu'on fait du lundi au vendredi et aussi
disponible en version podcast pour ça
vous tapez Hugo et crypt et vous allez
pouvoir le retrouver n'hésitez pas à me
dire cette vidéo vous a plu directement
dans les commentaires encore merci à
jelly smack pour son soutien je vous
mets les liens directement en
description prenez soin de vous et on se
dit à la semaine prochaine